pensa a tutti ragazzi benvenuti ha visto
ruby io sarò fa vj e strano che
continuino a fare dei giochi wac ragazzi
però il fatto che la gente continui a
creare livelli di happy with non mi
stupisce quindi non mi stupisce mango
questo sta sbagliando perché sta tizia
fa proprio una collana fantastica la
ragazzina come si presenta credo che sia
uno dei più belli poi magari non lo so
patrick si sta godendo la notte la
serata fuori alba e vabbè ho capito
farmi leggere questo e patrick allora
capello che sei padre doveva cos'è la
lasci così stava rimorchiando e tattica
da rimorchio perfetta zio complimenti e
va bene in via la ragazza istruzioni
trova tutti i modi per uccidere quei
deficienti va bene hai una voce che dire
sensuale e poco zio
quindi io sono la tipa non l'altro al
bagno con l'andata fumare ma può essere
così deficiente ma allora direi di
ucciderli con questo bel binello e va
bene
mischiate iron man sa teaser questo
potrebbe far male trionfa e ventoso e
sia andata ancora bene che non sarà
infilato in qualche orifizio strano
perché poteva andare molto peggio
sempre che non capiti a lui è andato
abbastanza bene entrambi in realtà
perfetto legittima difesa zia veramente
no vabbè se clicchi va tutto indietro
bellissimo geniale sua cosa
la smetti di fare versetti milan e
fastidio giovanni
come ammazzare dei ladri con jukebox
ragazzi ma di che stiamo parlando
e poi non sono live non solo malvivente
avete perso di vista la ragazza per un
juke box almeno la canzone è carina
e va bene ok questa buona che sappiamo
chi è questo che batista eva premi che
il casinò ha senso star o qualcosa mi
che ho appena visto quindi l'obiettivo
di stare aver a cambiare il musical
saltando sul box va bene ma comunque sta
cosa che si resetta tutto il livello
andando all'indietro e stufe o le
freccette questo oggetto ne richiede un
altro per poter funzionare va bene non è
il cammello il bagno questa la stecca a
quanto sono stupido presto per forza dai
sia fatti valere forza e va bene un
tempo rimorchiava tipo al bar finché non
mi sono beccato una freccia nel
ginocchio conca ragazzina la facilità
con la quale riesce ad uccidere si
inizia è disarmante
diciamo grazie per mano di un altro giro
io penso all'altro che è andato giù come
niente affatto sono spavaldo come la
madonna gioco di squadra grande 0 dopo
te la do ma è morto si è molto direi che
morti l'ombrello sapienti l'ombrello
nell'anno il loro regalo zio e va bene
quarto il casinò potresti essere un po
meno violenta perché non fa niente
ho capito ma non fa niente facciamola la
matita come fai a uccidere due ladri che
ama vestire ogni numero 505 allora il
mio numero di telefono e 55 54 54
attaccati a sto cazzo
e vabbè che questo comporta cenere in
faccia e morto non hanno capito non
volevo metterti alla prova comunque
barman non si scompone mai e per lui è
normale vede di queste scene tutti i
giorni con la porta del bagno
spiegami come posso fare
cosa centra la porta del bagno
spiegamento di questi ragazzi io
statista quando la cavo è veramente la
figlia di jackie chan è una roba del
genere del tipo non sia ovviamente a
costo di niente quindi becca testa
capocciata cosa fa lo stupro è
addirittura e questi ragazzi miei
succede a farlo con una donna che ha le
sue cose ovvero la stecca da biliardo
reagan
noi facciamo la stecca più i miei
capelli con i miei capelli ma cosa c'è
una brusca stati già
ma veramente io non ho capito presa e
già questa per un uomo e la morte prove
ma santiddio che se la parrucca molto
perché si va bene va bene morto è morto
basta un effetto cos'è una forcina ma
cosa serviva la stecca la b non lo
voglio sapere
non voglio sapere a cosa serve la stecca
da biliardo ragazzi non si è capita
stava prove col cappello come faccio
uccidere le persone comuni e va bene ma
ho già fatto borghi più sentiti e non ti
spaventare sono cose che si scrivono
così jean casse manco xvi nava già su un
bordello wolf rythme musique e sa come
trattare gli uomini si collabori seccia
asso delle robe dentro la borsetta
addirittura col rossetto col rossetto
veramente e adesso sono curioso di
vedere come un rossetto può diventare
un'arma letale lo stai solo mettendo non
è greco cioè cosa devi fare e provarla
anche tu ha detto sì ma scemo lo puoi
provarlo sul bene
[Musica]
cazzo va bene questa questa è la morte
per un uomo non quella di prima mi sono
sbagliato scusateci accademico una
ragazzina una domanda tutto questo il
mio a ragazzo nemici è andato affatto
male 0
secondo me ha fatto più male come lui sa
quello che si via le mazzate peggiori e
ragga tra i due lui e quello che se la
piglia veramente pesanti il tipo non può
essere morto con uno sgabello in faccia
l'altro si si in mezzo al sinai lo sarei
al peperoncino ragazzi scusa buon uomo
mi tiene un secondo la borsa mentre io
faccio vedere a questi stronzi il nome
si comanda
ciao zio non è ancora visto la forte
migliore scientifiche sound grande
perfetto non abbiamo l'ultimo oggetto
della borsa che non ho capito un taser
gun quanta roba per difendersi già stati
zie allora questo è il mio taser quando
hanno comprato dai sede mieri mezzo che
si vogliono bene ho capito ho capito che
si creda se sembrava perche non la
finiva più ragazzi che dopo la palla da
biliardo va bene come sai con una palla
da biliardo ad uccidere delle persone lì
a dargliela da in testa fortissimo
volete giocare a biliardo signori delle
rimodernate una bella signorina è
ovviamente ne approfitta per guardarmi
sotto la gonna cio non e contento sto
del vigente non si sbircia brutto
strappo non è tipo sarà mica incazzato
che botta in faccia no non lo fare non
lo fare tu odi occhi ai presenti e sasha
gray zio
ecco molto peggio ma quanto spazio ce
l'ha dentro hub è sempre frasi ambigue
rialzi prove di seriamente se arrivati a
15 pm 14 e non so che cosa fare questo
periodo al piano di sopra c'è il piano
di sopra ha lo trascino so va bene 4 che
quant'è forte sta tizia due minuti dopo
non ti sembra di esagerare un pochettino
no ragazzi ma questo è il mio ragazzo
che cantò ci fa fuori a bere birra da
solo c'è ma mi chiamava terapia e la
notizia ma che cazzo vai fuori delle
scarpe
i tacchi con i tasti nicchia che male
credo che questo faccia più male al
solito donne i cori o no fa niente fai
finta che non mi ha detto niente
a miami incalza viene pure quale non
credo che abbia fatto molto prima le
corone i [__] questa cosa però c'è
un altoparlante va bene
spiegatemi come con questo è successo a
servizio di prima
ragazzi è uguale a batista sto qua non
so perché credo che vi faccia
leggermente male però ragazzi non è
maschio e channel riguardo per i
gioielli di famiglia infatti marito
credo che questo faccia meno male de
nava di nathan ake è ancora vivo no
scherzavo cioè non prendere troppo sul
serio quando dico le cose busti più pool
si è addirittura con due ragazzi quante
mazzate con due visto niente
che schifo ma dai che stava per frane
anche achille lanciata infatti non fare
niente di strano se i cabasisi non fare
interessanti così va ancora bene zia
l'importante è non toccare i gioielli
non ha toccato i gioielli miracolo
incredibile ci siano ragazzi siamo
arrivati tipo 18
ne manca uno non ho capito ai sbloccato
il finale kill the last call call tipo
che fuma a patrick mica viene avvertita
birretta con tua moglie di skill wire
action against sobriamente devo devo
intervenire io col mouse
evidentemente durante la kippah che dai
proviamoci madonna quanto sei bello
patrick cazzo ma ci da un parrucchiere
ha pure lui di mezzo e nemico amico
quello 3 contro 3 4 contro 2 fissa
poverini che cosa devo fare io gravi che
no è bellissimo cross a che rovescio
dove non era proprio una rovesciata
ragazzi lui e batista è quello della
tabitha più è troppo uguale mica che se
le porte in faccia
patrick fa qualcosa non hai fatta col
cazzo
il dolore alla schiena incredibile ma
ovunque sorridere o gli han tagliati i
capelli finalmente ci siamo ragazzi
mamma che svetta potentissima gli ho
dato può dire che ha posto a calciare
cristiano ronaldo e gol
e se ne vanno così va bene tutto a posto
chi è che pulisce il barman è sempre
contento almeno ne frega un cazzo sono
troppo forte ragazzi 19 su 19 è stato
devastante
ragazzi miei concludi l'episodio
ricordatevi che se c'è una bella ragazza
in un bar non importunate da voi
potreste non ritrovarvi piccolini quindi
io mi farei più domanda comunque che
sono i miei io con qualche episodio e
spero che vi sia piaciuto e come sempre
piaciuta sono un momento è un mi piace
doppio mi piace per i maroni del tizio
che non si ritrovano più anche a
parziali facebook come individuo tornare
dizione so se il city 16 si chiamano
possiamo visto